[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning it's a
time again to bring you some of the
stories that we call talk of the table
we each pick a story we want to share
with you
Eureka you go first well this one is
hopeful I think it's a lot of people
scientists are getting closer to a long
sought-after blood test to screen people
for possible signs of Alzheimer's
disease so scientists got together
recently the American Alzheimer's
Association said the tests correctly
identified 92% of people who had
Alzheimer's correctly ruled out eighty
five percent who did not have it giving
the test and overall accuracy of 88
percent a lot of people are impacted by
this whether you're parents grandparents
so five million people in the United
States and the early detection and it's
not as invasive as some of the other
tests that they have it means that you
know maybe a longer life and also
stopping the disease from sort of
spreading the way that it's so
encouraging and it can't come soon
enough people worry about it I like that